[Music]
does feel like this we've all come up
together in this show and we're all like
our careers are all growing at the same
time and you know we're leaning on each
other for advice and on how to handle
these new things coming to our way and
we're a team and we're community with a
family saasy beats praising her atlanta
co-stars at the shows any consideration
event where we also talked Domino what's
your stick I'm lucky 27 year old made
her mark on the big screen as the mutant
hero in Deadpool - nice what has life
been like after the buzz of that movie
you know honestly I was really really
nervous about what would change and what
wouldn't change but it's actually been
quiet fine people were telling me that
some actresses got death threats and
some people wouldn't be able to like you
can take the train you can't walk around
you're gonna see we're gonna stalk you
and like so I was kind of
catastrophizing because I was receiving
all that information but it's been
totally totally normal so it's been like
good it's like a little bit more sort of
being stopped on the street but I I
thought it would be a lot worse really
known as x-force
absolutely x-force it's the Domino is
going to be a leading lady how does that
feel how do you hope that they portray
that on camera for x-force um you know I
I don't know what direction they're
gonna completely take with x-force I
would personally like if there was ever
like a domino movie out I would love to
explore a an origin story so that maybe
maybe something like I might explore but
x-force I think they're gonna sort of
it'll be the team and sort of exploring
that again and
being you know everybody coming together
I don't want to give anything away in
the movie but I you know I don't know I
don't know I don't think a script is
even written yet so yeah as for her role
as Vanessa on Atlanta Ozzy hopes for the
best in the just announced third season
really sad to see that things ended on a
sour note for her Nanban but I got a no
where do you want them to go as far as
co-parenting it seems like you guys
might do pretty well yeah I I mean it
would be fun to explore them getting
back together don't know what's actually
gonna happen but you know I think that's
also to know that's like a real
situation I mean my my parents divorced
when I was five I co parented and you
know I think that's something we're
seeing too and to see how that can be
done amicably right you know because
that's that's important so we'll see I
don't know
[Music]